EKE
EK
>> ♪ ♪
>> Bret: IN OUR CONTINUING
SERIES WHATEVER HAPPENED TO,
CATCHING UP WITH THE EFFORTS TO
CATCH SOME RUN AWAYS.
LINDA VAUGHN ASKED TO FACEBOOK
WHAT HAPPENED TO THE AFGHAN
SOLDIERS MISSING IN THE U.S.?
SEVEN WENT MISSING IN OCTOBER
2016.
THERE WERE MORE PRIOR TO THAT.
SOME WERE FROM FORT BENNING AND
FROM FORT GORDON.
TONIGHT JENNIFER GRIFFIN HAS
SOME ANSWERS.
>> THEY CAME TO AMERICA TO HONE
THEIR MILITARY SKILLS.
152 AFGHANS WENT AWOL.
THE LARGEST NUMBER OF RECRUITS
TO DISAPPEAR.
6 MONTHS LATER FOX NEWS LEARNED
AN INTERNATIONAL 27 AFGHAN
TROOPS AT BASES ACROSS THE U.S.
RAN AWAY.
WHERE DID THEY GO AND WHAT
HAPPENED TO THEM.
SOME ESCAPED UP NORTH TO CANADA.
164 WERE CAUGHT AND SENT BACK TO
AFGHANISTAN.
9 REMAIN AT LARGE ACCORDING TO
NUMBERS PROVIDED BY THE
PENTAGON.
A DEMOCRATIC SENATOR DEMANDED
ANSWERS.
SINCE 11 AFGHAN TRAINEES RAN
FROM THE FORT IN THE SENATOR'S
HOME STATE.
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY LOCATEDED ALL 11.
>> WE WERE NOT GIVING THEM
PROPER SUPPORT.
THEY WERE OFFERED THE PERFECT
OPPORTUNITY TO BE SAFE AND
SECURE SOMEWHERE ELSE.
>> 2,750 AFGHAN SOLDIERS
RECEIVED U.S. BASED TRAINING.
THE AFGHAN EMBASSY HAS TRIED TO
ENSURE THEY RETURN TO JOBS IN
CABUL.
>> WE ARE DOING EVERYTHING WE
CAN TO ENSURE THAT DID NOT
HAPPEN.
>> THE PENTAGON HAS UNTIL MARCH
15th TO RESPOND TO THE SPECIAL
INSPECTOR GENERAL WITH THE
EXPLOSIVE REPORT ABOUT WHAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE AND ICE
ARE DOING TO KEEP AFGHAN OFFICE